[Music]
everybody is Charlie so we just got that
big Captain Marvel preview last week
where they revealed the scrolls they
confirmed that there was a secret
invasion storyline so I'll break that
down and how that ties to Hawkeye in
Avengers 4 so if you're new to the
channel we're doing another round of
that spider-man ps4 giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this so
what do Captain Marvel 20 years ago in
the past the scrolls in Avengers 4 all
have in common
a big fat Secret Invasion comic book
storyline Ben Mendelsohn is playing the
Talos character during the Captain
Marvel movie he's the leader of the
scroll Secret Invasion it is implied
that when the movie picks up they have
already invaded earth and sort of
masquerading as people of importance
they confirmed that Ben Mendelsohn's
character is going to be playing Nick
Fury's boss inside shield so they've
already infiltrated shield as of the
beginning of the movie which sounds very
much like Hydra and Winter Soldier
secret takeover this is not our first
rodeo the funny thing too is is that has
nothing to do with the Hydra storyline
so shield is just right for takeover
from all sides when the movie picks up
Nick Fury is a lowly desk jockey he
doesn't really understand any of these
wider cosmic threats
he's more old-school talking about cold
war problems with Russia things like
that very terrestrial threats they sort
of had a moment like that at the
beginning of the first ant-man movie
with the Hank Pym flashback where he
quit shield a couple years after that
Howard Stark dies they create project
Pegasus which was built to study alien
threats and energy sources just anything
that fell to planet earth that they
didn't understand pretty safe bet that
during the course of the movie Nick Fury
loses his eye because he trusted someone
that someone he trusted is probably his
boss who secretly Talos asked role even
though he Coulson who's also going to be
a part of the movie will get Coulson's
origin story he's a rookie agent when
the movie picks up in Captain Marvel
kill off most of the main scroll
characters during the movie the idea is
is that they don't get everybody one
survives the end of the movie into
present day so early theory there'll be
a couple post credits scenes one will
just be straight-up Avengers for
scene where Captain Marvel gets the page
from Nick Fury and knows to go back to
Planet Earth
the other one being the reveal that a
scroll survived and will wind up showing
up in present day is a character that
we've known this whole time like oh my
god that person that we've been
following for the last 10 years they're
a scroll what the crap that's where we
get to the Hawkeye storyline during
Avengers 4 there were just reports that
Hawkeye was filming scenes with Yakuza
types that would be wearing prosthetics
implying that they would be scroll
characters way back in the comics during
the kree-skrull war what happened is is
at the end of that the Illuminati formed
and told the Skrull Emperor to screw
himself and never bother earth again the
Emperor was so pissed off that he vowed
revenge on earth in about 30-40 years
after that after the events of Civil War
left earth torn apart and ripe for
takeover the Skrulls
finally made their move so that's why in
the comics The Secret Invasion storyline
came right after the Marvel Civil War
storyline but obviously the events of
the MCU have been a little bit different
we have the snap so earth is again right
for takeover so that's why would make
sense that we haven't seen any Scrolls
on planet earth since what happens
during the Captain Marvel movie 20 years
ago just because earth was relatively
stable and strong so it wasn't a good
time for them I'm not really expecting
Secret Invasion to be a huge part of
Avengers 4 it just sounds like Hawkeye
is gonna be tracking down and killing
Skrulls during the movie so just minor
part in the larger picture of them
fixing the universe that's what we
really need to focus on so that's why
they're using the Captain Marvel movie
to introduce the concept of Scrolls the
idea that they can look like other
people
The Secret Invasion storyline from the
comics as for why they actually want to
take over earth during the Captain
Marvel movie 20 years ago all Mendelsohn
said in his interview was that the
scrolls were quote-unquote
misunderstood in the Kree were
insufferable like they were terrible he
made a joke about cursing them out in
print because it was a print based
interview but I think it's a pretty safe
bet that the reason why they want earth
is more about resources and strategic
value than say Infinity stones because
we've already done that plot so much
like in the comics Ronan the accuser
wanted to use earth is a Kree military
outpost during the kree-skrull war it
didn't have anything to do with Infinity
Ward Thanos or the infinite
stones literally just wanted to plant a
flag in earth and turn it into a giant
base but like I said after this
flashback scene in the late 80s at
shield Howard Stark helped create
project Pegasus which we got an Easter
Egg for during Iron Man 2 I'll play that
clip in a second but pretty safe bet
that they'll also reference project
Pegasus or we'll see the origin of that
at some point during the Captain Marvel
movie yeah
listen you have a ball with that I know
it's gonna work a shower cap the Oracle
grid and some stuff out of storage come
everything from projects Pegasus Exodus
and Goliath get ready for a major
remodel back in hardware mode
how bad is it that's the problem sir we
don't know now because she already has
her powers what they might do is it
might just already exist like oh we
built this a little while ago because we
don't know exactly when she got her
powers and what year it is when the
movie picks up but it sounds kind of
like a Spider Man situation in civil war
like where you meet him and he's already
gotten the spider bite and been Spider
Man for a little while so if it wasn't
clear when they're studying the
tesseract in the original Avengers movie
and they destroy that base in the first
couple minutes of the movie they didn't
just built that it had been around this
whole time since before phase one I
wouldn't be surprised to if the device
which gave Captain Marvel her powers or
a version of the MCU psyche magnetron
was being studied inside project Pegasus
and had something to do with the scroll
secret invasion storyline but the really
interesting thing I know all you are
asking about is Jude Law's marvel
character because the funny thing is is
that they haven't confirmed that he's
playing Walter lawson marvel so if it
wasn't clear Donald Blake was the Thor
joke that was the persona that he
masqueraded as in the comics so it's the
same thing with Marvel he has like this
human persona because he looks human
he's pink skin Kree but that goes way
back in the comics and they've changed
some of that plot there are a lot of
theories that Marvel is trying to pull a
fast one and he's secretly playing jaan
raghav villain of the Captain Marvel
origin story but way way back when he
was first cast variety is the Hollywood
trade that reported that he is going to
be playing Walter Lawson who is Marvel
so when people say that he's playing the
original Marvel that's why just because
it was reported so long ago because she
already has her powers when the movie
picks up meaning that she already had
the origin they might just be trying to
play around that like and not confuse
people like when you think of Captain
Marvel they just want you to think of
breeland's character so just to be clear
when the Captain Marvel movie picks up
she's already left planet Earth because
Jude Law has asked her to join their
Star Force team on a mission that takes
place during this Kree scroll war in
that sort of the intro to the movie they
have a big action scene then she gets
called back to earth because of what the
scrolls are doing in their secret
invasion plot the really fun part of
that
obviously I've already talked about Nick
Fury how he'll get his origin story he's
just a lowly desk jockey but Coulson is
also a brand new agent fresh out of the
gates so he has absolutely no idea
what's going on and they'll be de-aging
him the same way they de-aged Nick Fury
but I talked about this a while ago too
the funny thing about Clark Gregg is is
that he almost looks exactly the same
now as he did 20 years ago in real life
so he actually probably doesn't need
that many special effects but you can
actually tell like this doesn't look
exactly like young Sam Jackson but let
me know in the comments below who do you
want that secret scroll in present-day
to turn out to be which character
there's a couple other videos that I'm
working on but leave all your requests
in the comments below
codename bacon congratulations you're
the latest giveaway winner for my last
big video please email me on the about
page of my youtube channel I'll do a new
round when I post new marble click here
to watch the post credit scene and
ending from spider-man ps4 and click
here for that spider-man far from home
Iron Man scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you